troisième semaine de tournage pour
l'équipe du téléfilm la loi de damien ou
richard berry ici avec l'actrice
florence thomassin campe le rôle titre
de l'avocat dans leur ombre
les figurants se prête aux différentes
prises pendant que leurs alter ego
patiente au restaurant d'à côté pour la
deuxième scène j'adore ma vie de labeur
et puis une équipe l'aller les comédiens
figurants sont vraiment très sympa ce
que disait thibault tout à l'heure c'est
à dire qu'entre deux prises
effectivement il ya du temps attentes
mais en fait on le voit pas passer parce
que voilà on est entre nous en toute
simplicité donc c'est plutôt plutôt
super sympa rue comme mode 300 figurants
ont été recrutés pour le tournage du
téléfilm 900 avait candidaté il ya des
candidats habituels qui ont déjà fait
plusieurs castings il ya des apprentis
comédiens ou des comédiens bah voilà qui
participent à la figuration parce que
c'est tout à fait normal c'est une
expérience de plus une façon de faire il
découvre la face aux verts d'un
réalisateur et d'autres façons de faire
qui n'avait peut-être pas imaginé
et puis on fait participer aussi bien
sûr tous les gens qui dans notre
entourage sont amenés à nous côtoyer un
moment ou un autre c'est le cas d'al
hicha réceptionniste dans l'un des
hôtels fréquentés par l'équipe de
tournage faire de la figuration c'est
une grande première pour elle j'espère
que ça va se passer mais j'ai pas le
tract en tant que tel c'est juste un peu
d'excitation
voilà de l'inconnu et puis de voir
comment ça se passe
on participe à la vie du tournage c'est
vraiment on est aussi important que le
décor que les acteurs que tout ça faut
que ça vive sinon voiture j'ai des
différences
le tournage de la loi de damien se
poursuit jusqu'au 13 août à tour cette
fois avec de nouveaux figurants ils
pourront se voir prochainement en début
de soirée sur france 3 de la comédie à
la sculpture le centre de création
contemporaine
olivier debré à tours accueille en ce
moment la première exposition d'alicia
quoi d'une jeune artiste berlinoise
adepte des labyrinthes où l'oeil et
l'esprit ces gars découverte ciller
bérénice plus failli et joël gérard doz
on est d'abord frappé par un bruit le
bruit du tic-tac de l'horloge démesurée
et angoissant nous sommes en danger
la pièce nous met en danger elle essaie
d'organiser un manque d'incertitude faut
passer à travers un mur
vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas de mur là et
en fait c'est un miroir arrive au
pouvoir voilà tout et tout les labit
ratti comme ça tout est interrogatif et
c'est bien là tout le mystère de
l'oeuvre d'alicia quoi nous interroger
sur le monde sur notre époque
originaire de pologne l'artiste qui vit
aujourd'hui à berlin elle nous perdre
troubler notre perception des choses
le public ne s'y trompe pas soit elle
s'en écarte soit il adore vous avez des
gens qui y entre et qui n'en sort plus
parce que c'est un habile ron parce que
ils se prennent au jeu
yahia vraiment un aspect ludique on est
happé par cette pièce et on y reste
et puis vous avez ceux qui ne sont qu'
on pas vu un truc qui qui qui voit pas
qu'il ya quelque chose qui nous
interpelle à ce moment là il passe et
repartent
dans la pièce d'à côté autres frissons
sorte d'exposition câline scopique que
l'on doit à deux frères deux hommes
attirés par le mouvement les couleurs le
vide
on se croirait presque dans un tunnel
interminable ou chemins tortueux
hypnotique
pourquoi c'est intéressant une oeuvre
comme ça parce que nous rappelle que la
peinture la forme mouvements sont des
choses qui continuent à nous fasciner
si vous regardez bien d'avoir ça change
tout le temps et puis vous entrez dedans
vous êtes ap que vous avancez plus ça
vous fait avancer c'est une sorte de
gouffre là c'est un autre gouffre
légumes d'une mère filmé en plongée
depuis un bateau propositions et merci
contemplative et abstraite un regard
singulier presque étrange qui à la fois
nous apaise et qui paradoxalement nous
inquiète
et c'est la fin de ce journal vous en
rappelle les principales informations à
violent incendie s'est déclaré hier dans
la zone industrielle de puiseaux dans le
loiret au cours de la nuit au moins 28
véhicules ont été détruits sur un grand
terrain à l'extérieur on ignore encore
les causes du départ du feu
une enquête de gendarmerie a été ouverte
et puis la lutte contre la jussie sur
les rives du cher cette plante invasive
a beau être très jolie elle envahi
l'espace au détriment des espèces
endémiques
alors depuis cinq ans la fédération de
pêche et de protection des milieux
aquatiques s'attache à recenser les
herbiers immense de cette plante et
travaillent en lien avec la métropole
tout val de loire particulièrement sur
le cher pour préserver la biodiversité
de la rivière à suivre l'édition
nationale et internationale avec à la
une ce soir peut être un revirement sur
la question de la vente d'armes à feu
aux états unis pour la première fois
donald trump a évoqué aujourd'hui la
question
il s'exprimait après les deux fusillades
qui ont fait 30 morts ce week-end au
delà de l'émotion et de la colère
suscitée par ces tueries
le suprématisme blanc ce mouvement
raciste a été fermement condamnées
retour de l'information régionale demain
à 12h jeu c'est de passer une très belle
soirée
[Musique]
le temps va changer cette